yeah I think there's a lot of wishful
thinking around AI one survey that I
like to talk about
um there was a survey a few years ago
where they asked people two questions
first question will Ai and automation
displace millions of jobs by the year
2030. and like 75 80 percent of people
say yes to that then they ask Will Ai
and automation displace your job by 2030
and only about 20 of people say yes to
that so we have this idea that these
tools are amazing and powerful and
creative and disruptive and they're
gonna you know change the entire economy
in the next 10 years but not my job I'm
a special I'm unique I'm creative I'm
human I'm untouchable so I do think
there's a lot of kind of wishful
thinking and almost hubris around this
[Music]
thank you
foreign
it is my pleasure to welcome back to the
podcast Newark times Tech reporter
co-host of the hard Fork Tech podcast on
the New York Times and author of this
very very timely book future proof nine
rules for humans in the age of
automation Kevin Bruce welcome back
Kevin good to see you
also Kevin's claim to fame he wrote the
very first article on Yang 2020
launching the campaign into the
stratosphere that happened you could
look it up it did and apparently
becoming a big source of motivation for
the campaign because I called I think I
called you a longer than long shot and
uh so you guys printed that out and put
it on your campaign wall and and used it
to psych yourselves up to prove me wrong
so you're welcome yeah yeah thank you
thank you I mean it was statistically an
accurate description of the time I
didn't take it badly but you know you'll
take whatever fodder you can get to pump
up the team totally and I'm frequently
wrong so it was a it was a good uh I
think I definitely got elevated to just
long shot at one point
it's a medium shot medium shot so uh so
uh you've been writing a lot about Chad
GPT uh uh that what you've categorized
which I totally agree with this
characterization by the way is like the
AI arms race that has been kicked off
some fascinating reporting on how there
were people
um at open AI that didn't want to uh
popularize how popular it was I I
suppose
first do you think that this is it and
when I say it I mean you know people be
talking like AI is coming I certainly
was running around saying AI is coming
this might be the first
General use application that the average
person understands and is using
yeah I think so at least of these new
large language models so really this is
a different kind of AI I mean we both
had The Misfortune of writing books uh
about AI like too early I think because
you know we wrote and I remember talking
with you about this you know back four
or five years ago and and it was sort of
a fringe topic then because you know the
economy was doing great
um you know people were you know
gainfully employed and AI wasn't really
doing all that much at least the normal
people could sort of see and touch for
themselves it was just an idea it was
like a Terminator science fiction thing
totally totally and I would go out on
the road I'm sure you did too and you'd
try to convince people that AI was like
you know this big transformative force
that was going to affect people's jobs
and livelihoods and communities and it
was kind of like yeah maybe someday but
it sort of sounded sci-fi and and now I
think really since chat GPT came out in
November people are a lot more receptive
to that message I mean I get people
every day you know asking me if their
job is in trouble saying you know
they're they're trying to figure out
career changes and you know what should
my kids study in school so they don't
get replaced by AI it really is is a
dinner table uh conversation topic now
in a way that it wasn't just a few
months ago if only someone had run for
president on those ideas that that
fellow
you're just too early Andrew I mean heck
I didn't think it was gonna arrive quite
this quickly I'll be honest with you
like I mean if someone had thrown a year
at me I would have said between 20 25
and 2030 uh was when AI becomes like a
general use technology I was off by
whatever you know two years or so
um but I will say to you that I have
spoken to multiple people who have said
that they're going to cut workers as a
result of this uh that and there have
been some public announcements to this
this effect but one one person I'll
describe he runs a very high-end uh
Consulting shop and he said that a
particular
research project has gone from six hours
for a smart person to complete to 40
minutes for a person to complete uh and
he says I'm gonna end up laying off half
my people like he's not going to do it
today or tomorrow but is he going to do
it six months from now nine months from
now probably uh I had another person
who's a media a personality say that he
had a number of assistants who were
researchers who were supposed to do
stuff for him and he finds himself does
not not using them and that his main
move now is what he calls prompt
engineering which is just to be
thoughtful for a couple of minutes as to
what to ask the AI and then he gets
something back and uh and then he can
hone it
um in like a couple of minutes uh and so
then he's he's wondering like why why am
I keeping these people around so like
that kind of thing is playing out in
real life in organizations all over the
place yeah and it's not just the jobs
that are going to be replaced by AI like
I mean as in you know you come into work
one day and your boss says sorry you
know but your chat GPT is doing your job
now it's all of the the businesses that
are never going to have to hire people
in the first place I mean you can now
start a Content marketing company or you
know a publication and and you know you
can do the work of many humans now with
this software and so you don't need to
you know just talking to someone who
said they don't really need to hire a
you know HR people anymore to go recruit
people because they can just you know
ask chechi PT to go out and do that so I
think we're just at the beginning of
seeing the labor replacement effects of
this
um but I I do think it's going to be an
issue going forward and what's so
interesting and I know you know we've
we've talked about this before and
you've written about it before and so
have I but this was not the order that
we thought the jobs would be replaced in
right we had this sort of idea as a
society that the first jobs that were
going to be taken out by automation
in the 21st century were blue collar
jobs cognitive factoring jobs yeah were
Trucking were you know retail cashiers
uh construction like those kinds of jobs
and so there was a lot of there were a
lot of people out there telling people
if you want a job that can't be replaced
by AI you have to do something creative
because creativity is this unique human
quality it turns out it's almost exactly
backwards
um you know the creative jobs are the
ones that the AIS can now do
um you know at levels that approach that
of a human and you know there's still a
shortage of truckers and construction
workers out there people who work with
their hands I mean these Blue Collar
trades and so I think we just we just
really have to adjust our mental model
of which jobs are at risk and when so
the St Louis fed categorizes 44 of U.S
jobs is either repetitive manual or
repetitive cognitive and and that here's
the dirty secret that most people don't
realize is that a lot of the white
collar jobs are pretty
repetitive I mean
one of the things that I tell people I
was a corporate attorney for officially
I think five months or something like
that but I was also a summer associate
and a law clerk at a very high-end firm
in New York in my 20s and a lot of our
work was really really repetitive and
Mindless you know it was like finding a
place a lot of it was which deal looks
the most like the deal you're looking at
right now go find the the deal template
and then find them a place like new
companies in there by the way that
library of deal templates was a very
valuable resource for this Farm because
this Farm had done a lot of deals so
it's unlikely that the next deal is
going to be like the first time it's
ever seen something uh and so when you
talk about educating people a lot of the
jobs that they head into
aren't exactly like a fount of high
order creativity sure yeah and I think
that applies even in some of the the so
so-called creative Industries I mean
artists and musicians who are really
scared of being replaced by AI
technology and I don't think they're
wrong to be no um because you know
obviously we'll still have Superstar
musicians I don't think Taylor Swift has
anything to worry about from AI but a
lot of musicians make a living as Studio
musicians making the kinds of
compositions that you know play in the
grocery store over the loudspeaker
people get paid to make that stuff and
now that can be done by AI so I I think
we just we just really have to be
careful in telling people you know
creativity is uniquely human yeah it's
so lazy it's generally incorrect you've
written that stable diffusion and Dolly
too are now able to automate a lot of
design work it's like a text to image
generator
and that's something that you would
think of as the Pinnacle of creativity
it's like you know user interface design
or something like that and now it's like
hey I want a simple
like I want a
simple you can even say video and then
you can just keep on giving a different
prompts until it comes close to what you
want yeah and and I think we should also
say like one of the other pieces of
advice that we gave to people for years
and years about how to you know prepare
for the future was to learn how to code
right that was that was sort of oh it's
the worst man it makes me so mad yet
right there were all these programs that
we're gonna learn take these out of work
you know coal miners and teach them
JavaScript and that was going to mean
that they would always have a job but as
it turns out the pieces of these large
language models that are actually some
of the best are the code writing pieces
where now you can you know you can build
an app without actually knowing any
programming languages you just tell the
large language model you know build me
the app and you give it the
specifications and it can pretty much do
it so I really think that the you know
I'm I really think that the model of
safety that we've had for sort of how to
how to avoid the sort of kill path of
these uh of these AI systems is just all
wrong and we need to really rethink it
thank you
you guys already know all about
expressvpn I've talked before about why
they are the go-to service for
protecting your online activity big Tech
should not be snooping on us and
profiting from what we do in our private
time expressvpn can also help access
content including thousands of Netflix
shows that might be available in another
Market you just beam in encrypted
surreptitiously and you can be a UK user
and all of a sudden all that fun BBC
content can be yours I could go on and
on about expressvpn it's a VPN that I
trust and I'm not surprised that CNET
wired and others have rated it number
one visit expressvpn.com yang right now
and get three extra months of their
service for free that's exp r e s s
vpn.com Yang
expressvpn.com Yang to learn more
foreign
[Music]
that's a great new term the kill path
the ai's kill path it's a little uh on
the way to your job hyperbolic I don't
actually think they're gonna be Killer
Robots anytime Kevin Bruce is AI job
kill path
we totally should because that's
actually a pretty reasonable description
so we talk about basic coding I mean a
lot of those jobs are going to get
automated they're actually some of the
most repetitive cognitive tasks out
there and it it frustrates me when
people talk as if you know what the
answer to everything is getting girls
and women and underrepresented
minorities to code like like that like
that that's going to solve the problem
it's like well you know if we automate
those jobs like you know
it's not exactly like a a winner there
are
um shortages and other segments of the
economy I mean like we have a very very
strange economy right now where uh the
headline unemployment rate is very low
but one of the underreported things out
there is that the labor force
participation rate declined
um with covid and then never fully
recovered where last I checked it was
like two and a half million American
workers left the workforce and didn't
come back so there's a lot of confusion
around here because if you and I were to
say to folks right now hey AI eating
jobs kill path they'd be like butt
headline unemployment so low and and I
feel like we're just going to be hearing
people talking that stat like no matter
what else is happening around them right
and and I think you know it's important
to say that like these predictions that
technology and AI specifically are going
to cause mass unemployment like they've
been wrong for a long time people have
been pulling the fire alarm on this for
many many decades Kevin one of the
things I want to say here is that it's
not even like it's not jobs are going to
go away it's what they called job
polarization which is you're going to
gut a bunch of like the middle end jobs
what you'd consider like like a basic
white collar job and then to your
earlier Point you'll still have
Superstars like yourself honestly like
if you were to say hey to a young person
like hey you know what do you think
about journalism as a career path yeah
you know you might be like I don't know
about that one
they're still going to be like a
superstar uh Tech writer I I certainly
hope so from your lips to God's ears
you know I mean so so
um so what you're going to do is you're
going to gut the middle which is by the
way an ongoing theme here in America is
like you know like uh eviscerate the
middle class and then people will be
like oh there are plenty of jobs out
there it's just the jobs are going to be
low-end service jobs that it does
doesn't pay to automate and then some
Superstar jobs at the top and then the
middle is going to
um you know diminish a number I I have a
slightly different take which is I I
think I think we're gonna start to see
jobs changing
um and maybe not going away but I think
that every job will become different
because it'll have to I mean think about
a you know a radiologist who you know
has spent their the first 20 years of
their career just looking at scans in a
lab I'm trying to find different
pathologies or tumors or you know
evidence of something wrong wrong that
person is now going to have to spend
more of their time doing other things
because that part of their job has been
automated and so maybe they have to
develop some new skills maybe they have
to you know become maybe they have to
specialize in something else maybe they
have to focus on a part of their job
that is more relational and one of the
categories of work that I've I think is
going to be protected from this is um is
what I call social work which is not
just social workers but it's work that
satisfies social desires
um so you know it's not just meeting our
material needs it's actually giving us
some sense of pleasure or value or
intimacy and these jobs that are are not
technically impossible to automate but
that will just not be as satisfying if
they're dude I'm gonna work on a robot
snuggler you just gave me the next big
idea
I'm pretty sure they already have those
hiring man or something now you have
recently written about uh Chachi pt4
enabled Bing thing and yeah you said
like hey it's it's actually pretty good
I don't remember if people remember this
I actually made like a disparaging
comment about being in like a
presidential debate stage or what I was
talking about like winner take all I got
it was it's like it's one reason why
you're not using big and then the next
day Microsoft like you know like yelled
at me about it um I felt a little bad
because I have nothing against Bing
um but but now if anyone's freaking out
it's Google yeah it's an amazing turn of
events Bing was this joke for many many
years it had you know low single digit
percentage of the search Market Google
was this impenetrable Monopoly and then
um a few years ago Satya Nadella the CEO
of Microsoft does this really
um kind of prescient and an incredible
thing he strikes this deal with open AI
this tiny AI startup in San Francisco
and he says you know we're gonna have a
deal with you we're gonna invest in you
and in return we're gonna get your
technology and start implementing it
into our products I was up in Redmond
Washington at the Microsoft campus where
now they have invested much more money
in open Ai and they've actually built
open ai's technology into Bing and and
into Edge their their web browser and I
was skeptical because it's Bing right
but it is amazing I mean I've been using
it now for a couple days and it's just
so much better than the traditional
search experience on Google you know you
ask it to plan a trip for you
or you know the most amazing thing was I
was I was just demoing it and I said you
know write me
a menu for a vegetarian dinner party and
it did it came up with some ideas and it
you know normally you just go it would
send you out to a bunch of food blogs or
recipe sites and you'd have to Wade
through it all and do it yourself but it
just it gave me a menu and then I said
take that menu and write me a grocery
list sort it by Isle of the grocery
store and tell me how much of each
ingredient I need to feed eight people
and it did it and it was instant and it
was like you know something I could take
to the grocery store with me uh that day
if I wanted to so that's like one
example of how it's different but it's
just it's got so many more features um
and it can do so much more than a
traditional search engine holy cow so
Kevin Roose kill path headline Google is
blocked
I don't know I know by that I wouldn't
go that far because they're still that
you know they're catching up and they've
said that they're going to be
incorporating AI into their search
experience pretty soon and they've got
you know a ton of great researchers and
talent and resources over there so I
would say it's too early to count Google
out but they are definitely scared well
they're reacting they're about to
announce uh their own AI uh uh release
barred cool name
um and and the fact is you know even if
Bing is uh better for a particular
period of time most people won't know
about that
underestimating that I think this could
be Bing's Revenge the Revenge of being
sat and then Satya can be there with
like you know
um uh holding like up a bloody sword
love it though
the forward tour is coming to a city
near you that means I'm coming to a city
near you I'm heading to San Francisco
Los Angeles Seattle Raleigh Denver and
more in the spring go to fordparty.com
to check out the upcoming dates or just
check out my social media primarily
Twitter unfortunately see you soon
[Music]
so you're you're seeing now uh massive
companies
invest and one of the things I said in
my book which is totally not out of date
by the way Kevin totally reads as if it
could have been written today but it
said that when you're in a startup
context one of the uh the sayings is
throw money at the problem uh and so
some companies will be throwing money at
the problem but what I said is like the
new saying is going to become throw AI
at the problem which I dare say a lot of
Smart Companies are going to be doing
yeah and and doing with results I mean
that's one of the amazing things about
this technology so AI researchers um
like to talk about something called a
capabilities overhang which is basically
when you have an AI system that can do a
lot of stuff and it it's it can do more
stuff than it is currently being
deployed to do so you have these AI
models that now like you could put this
in any number of companies you could you
know train it on
um all of your HR data and so instead of
going through some you know PDF that
you're never going to read you could
have a chat bot where employees can say
you know how many vacation days do I
have left or you know what's our work
from home policy and you could do that
in any number of companies you could do
that in any number of departments within
companies you could do that for customer
service you could do that for for lots
of other things and so this capabilities
overhang is where the technology is
actually more useful than Industries uh
have seized on and so we we now have
this process where companies are just
going to be catching up to what this
technology can do yeah and it is going
to be a bit of a rich get richer
scenario in a lot of context because uh
you know if you have the intellectual
horsepower and capital to deploy
um then you can put some smart people on
like hey guys like how can we
incorporate AI into our products and
then
um theoretically you'll be able to take
advantage of it
um it is extraordinarily powerful and
the trickiest thing right now is trying
to figure out how to harness and deploy
that power to benefit you whether that's
either you personally as you were doing
with your shopping list and planning a
trip which I totally want to try now by
the way because I'm actually trying to
plan
trip and as usual it's a pain hey what
do you want to do we can do it right
here I can do it in a new Bing wow man
sponsored by Bing Bing
let's just say let's say you want to go
on a trip to
um so I'll ask it like uh I want to go
on vacation
somewhere warm within a three hour
flight of New York
where should I go
uh it'll give me an answer here in a
second but I've done searches like this
um that I was pretty convinced we're not
going to work and uh okay it's saying
the answer is Puerto Rico but continue
yeah yeah Puerto Rico San Juan Puerto
Rico this is the average temperature
February is 83 degrees Nassau Bahamas
um and Montauk if you want a shorter
trip but it's not very warm in February
it's only 40 degrees average temperature
so you can see like this could be very
very useful and it does save a lot of
time clicking you know clicking you
don't have to click around on different
websites so I I spoke to another
journalist you may know Stephen Marsh
who got a sneak peek on some of like the
yet to be deployed uh AI
um and he said it's pretty crazy and and
impressive do you also I'm sure you do
because companies want you to to see
their before it comes out so you
can write breathless reports about it
so yeah so like what's coming down the
the Pike in this realm where you were
like wow I didn't know I could do that
so one thing that's going to be
interesting is
um just the the continued growth of
these so-called multimodal language
models so language models that can do
text but they can also do images they
can do video video is really interesting
to me because you know right now you
know we've had CGI in movies for years
but it's very expensive only the biggest
Studios can afford to to do CGI and
these AI image generators are basically
going to put that into anyone's hands so
wow you can be a person with with no
money and make something that looks you
know like it took lucasfilm you know
millions of dollars to do
and it's also going to be a real
challenge to keep that from being
misused because you know you could
generate a a video of you know uh I
don't know Andrew Yang
um
killing someone
and put it up on the internet and all of
a sudden you're getting calls saying I I
think I just saw you I look I look
forward to denying my killing that
person
well it'll at least give you an alibi
you know well I mean that's where we're
gonna get to Kevin is that you can show
a video of me doing something I'd be
like fake
deep pink yeah and then the people that
like me will be like oh yeah that was
totally a fake and then the people that
that don't like me would be like he
killed that person jail him but I mean
we're we're going to be at that stage in
no time uh I mean we're we're nearing
that stage now where people are in
different versions of reality it's hard
to convince them so so you're going to
start a new Disney with this AI Studio I
think interesting I don't know that
though that started but someone will
start it and I think it's going to be
really interesting to see how Hollywood
responds to this I also think journalism
my industry is going to be really
interesting I mean we've already seen
um CNET had a AI journalism Scandal a
few weeks ago did you hear about this
one no please they were um so seen at
the the tech news site was using AI to
write articles and they didn't really
announce it and they didn't really say
what they were doing and and then people
started noticing that there were errors
in a lot of these articles because these
large language models they're quite good
and amazing at many things but they do
not have a sense of what is true and
what is not true that is like not their
primary strength they're they're you
know they've been calling you needed
someone to read this thing and just make
sure it made sense and I guess you know
it failed in that right and so and so
this is gonna I think keep happening
where companies you know are going to
start using these AI models to produce
kind of low value content and it's Just
Gonna Fill Up search engines it's going
to be hard to avoid and and I think
that's really going to be a problem so
that's another area where I'm I'm hoping
that companies will be smart about this
and not just race ahead and try to cut
costs and and do this you know to churn
out a bunch of worthless crap
good
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
having a good mattress has always struck
me as one of the best investments you
can make because you spend a lot of time
on that mattress and having a healthy
night's sleep gives you energy for the
day keeps you healthy makes you capable
of doing all the things you want to do
why would you sleep on a mattress that's
made for someone other than you
especially in 2023 with Helix sleep you
can take a personalized quiz get one of
their 14 unique mattresses sent right to
your door have a hundred night trial and
a 10 plus year warranty yeah they have
that much confidence in their products
in part because they're manufactured
right here in the USA and it's the
number one mattress picked by GQ in
Wired Magazine Helix is offering 20 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners go to helixsleep.com
yang this is their best offer yet and it
won't last long with Helix better sleep
Starts Now
foreign
someone asked me on a like a Twitter
space the other day they were like hey
um like why do we have to let AI do this
like you know like can can you have
decisions
um that that we all come together and
say maybe we shouldn't do that and I I
my response to that person was like well
look at governments approach to social
media companies they had no idea what's
going on social media they had they
wrote section 230 uh in the 90s before
Facebook even existed and then this
trillion dollar industry arose and the
government wasn't there being like Oh do
this do that and now you have these
quasi-public utility like things where
it's like uh you know it's the the
equivalent of the Town Square
um and you you have members of Congress
just uh posturing around these issues
and really is the company that has to
make these choices and I said in this
context using AI you're talking about
the operations manager of an insurance
company uh looking at what he's doing
and saying hey you know what I think I
can get this done with you know like uh
with uh 20 fewer people or 50 fewer
people where the heck is the government
going to be in that manager's
consideration is that nowhere you know
it's just gonna make make a call and
then say it like you know get padded on
the back I mean there's a conversation
around this stuff that I personally like
want to try and
um improve uh and you know but a lot of
it to me
um is is more wish wishful thinking than
anything based in reality what do you
think yeah I think there's a lot of
wishful thinking around AI
um one one survey that I like to talk
about
um there was a survey a few years ago
where they asked people
um you know two questions first question
will Ai and automation displace millions
of jobs by the year 2030. and like 75 80
percent of people say yes to that
then they ask Will Ai and automation
displace your job by 2030 and only about
20 percent of people say yes to that so
we have this idea that these tools are
amazing and powerful and creative and
disruptive and they're gonna you know
change the entire economy in the next 10
years but not my job I'm special I'm
unique I'm creative I'm human I'm
untouchable so I do think there's a lot
of kind of wishful thinking and almost
hubris around this and you know I've
I've made peace with my own eventual
obsolescence and I just hope that the
robot overloads will be merciful when
they put me out of a job they like you
Kevin I have a good authority some of
them do some of them don't I do give
them a lot of weird assignments you're
you're going to be one of their human
interfaces for sure
um so so when you dig into the what goes
on the job market and you talked about
the Radiology just someone that came to
mind for me is a University employee so
the the fact is a lot of people's jobs
right now uh are dependent less upon
like hey could AI do your job
theoretically it's it's more about hey
this organization uh like what are its
incentives uh and what are its resources
at a particular moment in time
um so if you're a university and let's
say I came to a University registrar and
was like Hey like you can get rid of
half these employees like you know you
just do this stuff with AI like is the
University's culture such that they're
going to turn around and do that like
maybe maybe not like maybe if like a
really hard time comes to that
University
um if you're a Public Employee it's the
same thing you know like the the issue
is that like healthcare when you talk
about the radiologist
um Healthcare is going to be one of
these protected Industries because even
if you can do some things with AI like
the medical lab you'll just be like it's
got to be human doctor gotta be human
this looking at an emerald shrug and say
sure patient care
is that uh it's going to get tied up in
organizational incentives it's going to
get tied up in regulation in certain
parts of the economy then there are
going to be certain workers in certain
industries are going to use ad agencies
as an example that comes to mind where
it's like we don't give a about
what goes on
that like like the Ad Agency is going to
be like purely efficiency driven
insurance company same thing uh you know
it's like a financial institution same
they're going to be a very ruthless
Market efficient actor and if they look
around and say hey turns out I can do
this this uh Department's job with half
the workers then we're going to do it so
you're going to see different parts of
the economy respond in different ways
and I and I think that there's going to
be an instinctive sense of this and
people are going to go try and flow
towards areas that are more politically
protected that's an interesting Theory I
mean I I do think that the model that
people have of AI replacement where you
just walk in one day and you find out
that you lost your job and everyone's
been laid off and I think that's that's
never quite been true but I think it's
especially not true with AI because
what's going to happen it's not that the
hospital or the insurance company or the
consulting firm is just gonna you know
install some Ai and then fire 50 of the
workers the next day right it's going to
be more often that there's a new startup
that does a lot of the same stuff as the
hospital or the consulting firm or
whatever else but it uses Ai and so it
only has you know 20 people and it's
doing the work that the competitors need
hundreds or thousands of people to do
and is that small company takes over
market share from this much bigger
company the bigger companies going to
have to do layoffs and the smaller
company is going to stay pretty small I
mean one example I I wrote about in my
book is what's been happening in China
with this company called my bank my bank
is a is a lender they lend you know
billions of dollars a year for home and
car loans and stuff like that and their
Innovation is this proprietary automated
system that they basically claim can you
know evaluate someone for a loan and
make a decision about it with no human
being required it's a totally software
driven AI approach and because
media and see if I seem reliable like
what do they do I have no idea
um they have it's it's probably similar
to something like a social credit score
or a regular credit score they I'm sure
they take some information from your
bank and they basically assess your
credit worthiness and issue you alone on
the spot with no underwriter or or you
know loan officer there to do it and
because they've been so efficient
they've been able to take a lot of
market share from these Banks and Loan
firms that have tens of thousands of
loan officers who are sitting there
manually you know approving the loans
and so you know those Banks and and you
know lending firms are going to have to
lay people off eventually because they
can't compete so that's I think more how
it's going to go
I had lunch with a venture capitalist
yesterday and he was talking about the
general pullback and Tech valuations and
a bunch of other things uh said that you
know maybe half of venture-backed
companies might uh struggle to get fresh
powder in uh and so you're you also are
seeing announcements of layoffs in the
name brand companies like the the metas
and Googles and Apple's companies you do
not associate with pulling back uh
though it makes sense given that in some
cases their stock prices have come down
uh 50 or 60 percent so you were based in
Silicon Valley right
yeah in the Bay Area yeah yeah yeah
um so uh what are you seeing and hearing
on that front uh you know it like uh I
mean it's true also that good companies
get started in any period including in
in tough times but
um what does the retrenchment feel like
uh and are you seeing and hearing
anything about this wave of
venture-backed companies and the next
step for them yeah so I it you can
definitely sense it out here in the bay
um there have been these big rounds of
layoffs at Google and meta and other
companies and
um I think you know there's
a sense both of kind of fear how long is
this going to go on
um I think these companies you know many
of them may have over hired during the
pandemic and in expectation that the
pandemic bump would last forever
and when it didn't and the advertising
Market slowed down and inflation you
know and interest rates went up
um you know those businesses are have
fallen on Hard Times some of them and so
they they needed to make some Cuts but I
think there's also some excitement about
it especially if you talk to like people
who are at younger startups people who
are maybe investors people who who have
really it's been very hard for Tech
firms
that are not trillion dollar monopolies
to compete for talent out here you know
the starting salary for an engineer you
know at Google or or meta or any of
these big companies is astronomical and
so if you're a startup that just raised
you know a 10 million dollar seed round
or something like that it's very hard to
compete and and it's very hard to get
the people that you need so I think
there's also some excitement about the
fact that some of these people who get
laid off in these big tech companies are
not just going to go back to another
tech company they're going to go into a
startup they're gonna you know raise
money and do their own thing they're
going to maybe go work at a at a company
outside of tech that needs Tech workers
so I think there's a sense in which they
they feel like these big companies have
had a really a Stranglehold on a lot of
the top talent and now that's being more
evenly dispersed
so you you joked about your book
um future-proof nine rules for humans in
the age of automation
um do you have anything that you'd want
to add if you could
no my book is Future proof it's it's
literally like you cannot it's literally
future proof I I could verify that his
book literally is future well so my book
came out before chat GPT obviously and
some of the the language models and I
actually think I did a decent job of
um you know sort of laying out like what
some of these myths around Automation
and air are I think I think it holds up
pretty well I was just reading through
it the other day I had to give a talk on
it soon and I think it holds up pretty
well I think the the one thing that I
would
um
that I would change I think I I think I
was I was not thinking enough about the
sort of optimistic case for how you can
actually level up your career or your
life by kind of learning about these
systems and how they work I mean the
emergence you mentioned prompt
engineering yeah as an example that's
going to be the freaking skill people if
you are scared just Google or Bing
prompt engineering and then become an
expert you can you can have your prompt
engineering shop they're going to be
like Legions of middle-aged Americans
that'll be like oh can you help me with
the right engineer with the right prompt
anyway yeah so prompt engineering is a
job that I did not see coming but that
turns out to be like a really important
skill right now is figuring out how to
get the the best output out of these
language models
um so I think yeah I mean you know every
author wishes they could add to their
book after it's published but um that's
one thing that I would I would add is is
some of these new jobs that are opening
up because of these language models yeah
and you have a weekly podcast hard Fork
uh tell people about it and uh and what
what you're excited about on that front
yeah it's a weekly type podcast from The
New York Times called hard Fork I
co-host it with my friend and fellow
tech journalist Casey Newton
um we uh try to take a look at the
biggest Tech news of the week we
interviewed
um Sam Altman the CEO of openai which
makes chat gbt as well as Kevin Scott
who's the chief technology officer of
microscop Microsoft and we've
interviewed lots of other folks from the
tech industry too and and we have a good
time so you can find it everywhere you
get your podcasts all right Kevin Roos
we'll have you back uh then the next
time a major technology upends reality
which should be by my clock and
approximately five weeks
yeah I'll see you back here in March
thank you